[Music]
I'm Barry Allen I'm a fastest man alive
I also think that I am on the wrong
earth I'm gonna need your help
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got all kinds of
new crossover stuff to break down
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a flash
related comment on the video you guys
may have heard about all the Smallville
stuff that's happening during the
crossover the really cool thing they're
doing is crossing the streams in a way
that you never expected we always wanted
Smallville crossover they're casting Lex
Luthor on Supergirl season 4 even though
it's probably not going to be Michael
Rosenbaum they're still finding ways to
cross Smallville over with the air /
shows and of course because there's so
many different earths colliding together
during this year's crossover it makes
sense that they would try to do some of
the coolest Easter eggs in scenes
possible so what happened recently as
you saw during that Grant Gustin clip
they are filming scenes on the Kent farm
from the Smallville TV show only within
the story it's on super girls earth 38
and it's her version of Superman the
Tyler hoechlin earth 38 Superman with
Lois Lane played by bitsy Tulloch if
you've never seen it before this is them
getting ready to film a scene in costume
so this is what she'll look like in the
episode does she not look like she could
be related to Margot Kidder so if you've
never seen this before this is the
actual house where they filmed all the
Smallville Kent farm scenes back on that
TV show so the air overs production for
the crossover has just gone back to that
place now obviously we're probably not
gonna spend a whole lot of time there
because you've seen black costume Tyler
hoechlin on maybe a different earth with
Stephen Amell as the flash this is
actually what he looks like in that
flash costume I know that they made a
new cowl for him because we saw pictures
of that earlier this year but they may
have made an entire new costume for him
but I think they redesigned the flash
costume this year with the crossover
twists in mind the scene that you see
him filming in his flash costume I think
is just a random takedown of a rogue
like it's gonna be the big surprise oh
my god it's the flash but it's actually
Stephen Amell it's not Grant Gustin and
he'll just be taking down some normal
rogue so what they might do is is
because it's crazy to have him as the
flash and he's such a hardcore character
is Oliver Queen
maybe this will be like the hardcore
earth and that's why Tyler hoechlin is
wearing the blah
costume not because he's evil Superman
just because he's a much more hardcore
injustice style Superman if you've never
played the injustice games Superman is
off the chain he goes completely nuts
it's a really dark story Clark no
even if I agreed that he should die you
can't we need him alive to save the rest
of our cities no we don't with more time
and cyborgs help the ship will obey me
so maybe this is just the darker version
of the characters where Oliver Queen
became the flash and Tyler hoechlin is
flying around looking like a badass but
just keep in mind multiverse many
different versions of the characters
there was another scene that we actually
have footage of with Barry and Oliver
dressed up as the trigger twins they're
criminals running from the Central City
Police Department here's that clip
[Music]
you can kind of hear the dialogue that
Barry is speaking saying oh my god this
is so bad trying to catch their breaths
they're running on foot meaning that
Barry does not have super speed maybe
there's some crazy timeline changing
going on and that's also how we get to
our Stephen Amell version of the flash
maybe that just happens a couple times
during the episode the other really
funny thing you guys may have seen is
Stephen Amell has been posting a whole
bunch from behind the scenes he posted
this funny comment about Jensen Ackles
let me squash this rumour right now
Jensen Ackles was on set because he's
grant gustin's number two fan I'm number
one and not because he's playing the
Batman just having a little bit of fun
with people as you can see Canada graphs
got pictures of Jensen Ackles visiting
the set of the crossover I don't know
which episode this was from but because
they shoot Supernatural in Vancouver a
little ways away from where they shoot
most of the air over shows is that that
heart for him to drive over to the set
and say hello to everyone
and because the crossover production is
so crazy big and there's so much cool
stuff going on of course all their
friends who are actors up there want to
get a look at what they're doing behind
the scenes
he has joked about Jared and Jensen
cameo iing in the air overs but they've
never been able to make their schedules
work or have like a really compelling
idea for them but I would like to see a
version of him - Hal Jordan inside the
arrow verse because it's gonna be so
long before we see that Green Lantern
Corps movie that you might as well do a
little bit of green lantern on TV but
for some crazy reason Warner Brothers
has not let them do any live-action
Green Lantern stuff so I'm not expecting
any big twist but Stephen Amell also
teased that there would be a lot of
Easter eggs in the backgrounds of scenes
that would blow people's minds so I
wouldn't be surprised if we see green
lantern stuff in the background of shots
without actually physically seeing a
green lantern on screen that's kind of
how they've been treating Batman on all
the arrowverse shows thus far you
mentioned him you include Easter eggs
but you haven't seen him on frame yet
there was some confusion the other day -
people thought because of all this Tyler
hoechlin Superman stuff is going on
during the crossover
it means the CW is developing a Superman
TV show and that is not the case there
is no Superman TV show in the works
there is a metropolis TV show that
they're making for the DC streaming
server
but that went back to the concept phase
a long time ago because it was supposed
to be a Lois Lane Lex Luthor TV show
that for whatever reason the network
decided they didn't like that idea so
hopefully if that ends up moving forward
it will incorporate Superman and it'll
be a more legit Superman TV show but
that would be on the DC streaming
service if you want to talk about
conspiracy theories I do think that the
reason why they were able to use Tyler
hoechlin Superman so prominently during
this three-way crossover is is because
of all the Henry Cavill stuff that's
going on now because of the rumors that
he's leaving but because of the rumors
that Warner Brothers isn't actively
planning on doing any Superman movies
anytime soon usually that's when Warner
Brothers chills out about letting those
big characters go on TV now obviously
there's a Wonder Woman movie coming up
there's still the Batman movie coming up
so with a brief exception for Titans
just don't expect those characters to
show up because we do have Wonder Girl
on Titan's Donna Troy and we do have a
version of Batman once they do start
dropping more of their scenes in
episodes I'll do more Titans videos for
that but leave all your requests in the
comments below as we get more previews
of the crossover I'll do more crossover
videos to Marvel just announced a brand
new phase 4 movie schedule so I'll do a
new video for that tomorrow there's new
daredevil and new Titans so whole bunch
of stuff coming up congratulations la
gee you're the giveaway winner for my
last big DC video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of the New Avengers 4 trailer and click
here for the brand new flash trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]